also want to touch less grass as well
how sure want to play more video games I
[ __ ] yeah man I do but I don't at the
same time yeah I do but I don't at the
same time I'm like I can I can do that
in my retirement yeah sometimes I play
games and I think man was it worth it
was it worth losing a day like I I like
even if it's a game you're enjoying
right
um some side effect really depends like
Elton ring I never felt that like the
[ __ ] was so God tier that I felt like I
had to that's what you get for being a
[ __ ] TFT player man oh yeah if I
spend a day playing League or TFT or
OverWatch something like that uh I I do
regret it oh yes that's why I stopped
playing competitive games because it
always feels like it's so easy to get
addicted and into the garage yeah but I
I always felt like after I finished
playing it I'd wasted a day especially
if you're on the ranked table and you
lose yeah you're like okay I made
negative progress today and I didn't do
anything I just gotta know it but that's
why it's great like in places like I
really enjoy like like as you well know
um portable gaming I don't particularly
prefer it but I do like the fact that I
don't feel bad if I would put my laptop
and play a game of TFT at the airport
yeah I I I'm like I don't feel guilty
about that I'm killing time and I'm I'm
enjoying yeah yeah yeah yeah which is
why I like seem back you like a lot I
[ __ ] love my steam deck start the
trail series now that's good that's my
New Year's resolution
he wants to [ __ ] play more games bro
I'm like if you know what if you don't
if you don't know what that is good good
don't find it oh yeah we talked about it
we talked about a previous episode and I
followed through I'm 15 hours into uh
the first Trails game
I bought the game and but I haven't
started yet I'm scared bro I think I've
only had like in the past like two weeks
since we spoke about it I've had like
two hours three tops yeah but it's it's
I would never have started playing it if
I didn't have my steam deck so I didn't
realize this but when we were on tour
like
um in America you could just buy a steam
deck now in Japan you can now Japan just
now but we've been on a waiting list for
like months and months and months here
in Japan uh so I bought one to Sydney's
house and I had a steam deck and I
didn't know what to play but like now
I've just been you know just it's just
been my activity to do before I go to
bed it's just perfect perfect little
jrpg play go to bed and just you know uh
yeah I really wanted to get it and I was
on the waiting listed like 10 bucks to
go on the waiting list in Japan yeah and
I've got the email like two days ago or
three days ago that was like hey you can
you can now get it if you want right and
I saw the prices like it's a grand and I
was like
damn it's a grand for the the good model
oh it's a gaming PC it's a portable game
yeah I just kind of was like I actually
don't think I'm gonna use it like and as
much like because I yeah I I really
wanted it just because I'm like I'm a
huge Tech guy I [ __ ] love my tech I
love getting Tech yeah and I wanted to
get it just because I really admired the
product and I thought what it did was
amazing yeah but I did I just sat there
I was like I actually just don't like
realistically am I gonna use it I don't
think I'm gonna play TFT I'm not gonna
use it yeah I can't I like it should
like to your teacher doesn't work on it
right so I don't know that was that was
a stroll like both the Camelback
no purchase I sat down and I thought
yeah genuinely like watch Steam games do
I actually play yeah yeah and I realized
I was like none I literally don't play
Steam games that's why that's why I
didn't even get onto the waiting list
because I'm like I don't play I don't
play steam as it is yeah it looked cool
I just thought it'd be fun because like
you you say like do do you feel like you
wasted a day playing video games and
like you know playing playing the games
I am now finishing God of War you know
playing the trail series now I don't
feel like I wasted a day actually
because that's games you like actually
like you know are invested in one yeah
and I'm going to remember my experience
I'm not gonna forget my experience with
god of war and stuff like that that's
something that's going to stick with me
and that's why I like story driven games
right that's because it's it's something
that I'm going to remember the
experience playing this game I don't
feel like I wasted a day by making
progress in this game because I do feel
like I am making progress in this game
you know so it's just like yeah I'm
going to remember my time with it so no
I don't feel like I'm going to waste it
that sense yeah I kind of have that same
feeling with like when I like read a
book or something right where it's like
you know some people be like oh am I
wasting a day reading a book yeah I was
like well not really because you know at
the end of the day like a story driven
game you are remembering a story and
that story anything that makes you happy
is not positive or negative way is going
to have an impact on you right yeah and
what you can choose to use you can
choose not to use yeah but like with
like a competitor game for instance it's
like I'm not as invested in it because
at the end of the day the only thing I'm
going to remember is was I pissed off at
the end of the day yeah did I make
progress no well
after our Guilty Gear stream I was like
[ __ ] I really want to play more guilty
here
I was just like I really really do but I
I just like the thing that's stopped me
it's just I just I just don't gel with
competitive games right because I get to
this point where I really like I really
like learning competitive games but when
I get past that point and I feel like
you're just grinding the ladder you've
learned the mechanics
um I just that's when I start feeling
like I've wasted time on this game you
know well I think the one benefit that
competitive games have over story is
that like there's a clear start and end
to a game you know what I mean like like
if you play like Hearthstone you know
you could play like two three games 20
20 30 minutes yeah you can get out your
game is over you can you have that you
have that window of like do I start
another game or do I just go back to
work yeah do something else right yeah
and I think that's the one thing that at
least like like Alden ring it's like
dude it's like never like there's never
a break like it's always go go story the
world and so I kind of like competitive
games in that sense where like sometimes
I will boot up just play two games of
OverWatch go back to work like it's a
yeah
you know if I have lunch and I eat my
lunch in 10 minutes but I I I believe
that I should probably take at least a
30 minute break doing stuff it's like
okay well now I'll um you know I'll play
two games if I've ever watched then I'll
go back to work or something or I'll
play one game of TFT or I'll you know
play a game of hearthstone yeah
that kind of mentality I like that
they're a clear start and stop times
right and it's very much up to you if
you want to see one one thing one thing
I realized because after coming back on
tour there was this like week two one
week or two week period where I I guess
like I had to like re-acclimate to the
normal work schedule again after I was
right back in it you're right back right
back two days [ __ ] like four like
four or five weeks until I was like I am
I need to just like not be in front of
an audience for a while be in my own
Zone I need to like I've touched too
much grass recently and it's like I'm
like I need to not touch grass for a
while yeah and I just like I just had
like a like a week-long period where I
just did nothing but just like catch up
on my anime and just play games and I'll
and go on dates with Sydney and spend
like some quality time and I was like
[ __ ] this is so nice and I've missed
okay I've missed
I I've missed this feeling of remember
when you're in school right and it was
like it was like a school holiday and so
you had like three months or something
so you just you just spend a whole week
playing nothing but video games and
watching anime and you had no pressure
to do anything because you knew that the
school year didn't start for like
another two three weeks or something
like that that to me is like such a
magical feeling that I'd forgotten about
because being self-employed you always
think you can be doing something right
you you you you can be working towards
something right there is no mental reset
of
school starts in three weeks therefore I
have three weeks to allow myself to do
nothing I believe what you discovered
was the feeling of retirement
that's exactly what God wants to retire
that just sounds like oh you're like oh
the return life is kind of nice I don't
have to think about doing work it's
always aggressive green on the other
side right if you were tired after a few
months of taking it easy you'd probably
be like
what no no make something you know what
I mean so what I'm talking about isn't
retirement and what I'm talking about is
balance actually I know yeah yeah no I
get that yeah because the idea of having
like three weeks off of doing nothing on
the same kind of three weeks off is a
bit too long but okay would you feel bad
okay would you feel bad if you like now
if you just took a week off right took a
week off from work and just played video
games oh yeah God yeah yeah why because
I'm not at that I'm not at that State
mentally right now where I can do that
and feel comfortable right it's like I'm
I'm kind of at this point where I like
taking breaks in between work days yeah
I'm like a break work day break work day
kind of mentality I I don't like just
doing like the full like work for one
week and then you can take a break for
one week yeah we're extremely uh Lucky
in a way where we can we actually have a
choice yes of course we can decide hey I
want to take a week off how busy we are
it's completely up to us yeah I think I
think a lot of people don't have that
choice
um and I think just being the ability to
take a week off is like I don't know
even in that itself is like that is kind
of fulfilling in a weird way right it's
like even though I'm not going to take a
week off knowing I can kind of helps me
it keeps me motivated in a weird way I'm
grinding now so I can retire faster yeah
it's kind of like it's like okay I'm I'm
I've worked really hard on on all this
YouTube stuff and of course we're all
very lucky we're extremely lucky right
um but we also we also I think we work
our asses off yeah um and I I think
knowing that hey if I want to take a
week off I want to take two weeks off I
have the ability and we've worked to the
point where we have that option I think
okay that enough is like very fulfilling
yeah I don't necessarily need to take
them off yeah yeah because like
guaranteed there are people watching
this that will just take a week off just
to [ __ ] do nothing right and I think
a lot of people don't like they get the
week off it's like this is your week off
now yeah because that's okay and all the
more power to them you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah do it [ __ ] do it yeah and
I'm just like because like for me for
example the reason I said play video
games is because
I like I think out of like the three of
us I probably game the least yeah
probably yeah probably yeah yeah and
part of the reason for that is because
like mentally I hate going into a video
game I hate gaming if I know that I
gotta stop after a certain point I love
going into a video game knowing I will
stop when I want to stop but if I go if
I ghost if I started but you can't sit
down and be like all right I play this
game for three hours and then I turn it
off no matter what and start working
yeah yeah I can't I can't be like I need
to be somewhere in two three hours so I
only have two three hours to play this
game even just even just knowing that
I'm like I'm not gonna start the video
game because if I'm really really into a
game I want to play until I I want to
stop playing I kind of get that feeling
yeah but the fact that even if you're
like three hours through that's a long
time three hours well in jrpg world it
is when when I'm into a game like I was
playing God of War for like five hours
minimum at a point just because I was so
[ __ ] invested right but like I love
that that feeling of like me like God
damn I gotta go I'm gonna do something
and then the whole time you're doing
this something you're like I can't wait
to get back to the game dude you like
that I love that for me that's how I
know I've got a banger yeah because I I
hate that because for me like I can't
focus on the thing I'm doing because I'm
just thinking about the video because
that's like the difference in like like
the skill diff
I wonder if that's like an ADHD thing
where like I I'm fine with that like
that feeling is fine I'm content with it
maybe it's I don't know like I I'm just
curious I just like I just love the
feeling I think this is with all media
for me I just love the feeling of like
being completely absorbed into something
I do [ __ ] hate it if I have to stop
watching something on like Netflix yeah
halfway through like an episode yeah
that pisses me off because I'm like can
we at least stop it like a checkpoint
yeah like if like the documentary is
like a 40 minute long three apps or
something and I've stopped 30 minutes in
I'm like well that's the same with like
a jrpg for me it's like I'd rather
instead of stopping at like the save
points right no but like there's there's
save points in a lot of games and then
there are like
story transitions right like I would
much rather I hate stopping at like save
points before something big in this part
of the story is about to happen yeah I'd
rather just power through if I if the
time lets me to just power through and
get to that point where the story then
takes a turn goes in a different
direction I'm like okay that's a good
place it's like it's like you know if
you're reading a book and you finish
like halfway through a chapter versus
just powering through and just finishing
the chapter no I agree I think that like
yeah that's obviously better
um but with the game sometimes those
things are so few involved between yeah
it depends on the points everywhere is
because you can just say it depends on
yeah for sure yeah modern games are just
auto save yeah some reason for some
reason jrpgs haven't figured that out
yet no yeah it's so weird because I'm
playing trails and it doesn't auto save
yeah so I'm so [ __ ] stupid so
sometimes I die in a [ __ ] fight or
something or or yeah sometimes I die in
a fight I'm like [ __ ] when did I last
save wait when did I last have to think
about saving before boss fight doesn't
just automatically do this me it's been
a while back in my day I saved three
times just to be sure I'm like did I say
it but did I actually say it no did I
really say it okay here's the real
question if you manually save do you
just have one save file that you
overwrite every time hell no or do you
have like [ __ ] 10 million dollars are
you are you a single saver or you're a
multiple of you ever [ __ ] I'm a
multi-file sailor for sure I'm I'm I
don't know 50 50. 50 50. I'm just like
I'm like every new checkpoint I go to
the new file and then if I run out of
files yeah but then if I run out of
files like say you know it's like 10 or
20 files if I run out of files I go back
and overwrite the first yeah because
you're never gonna go back to their save
files no you're not but it's just it's
comfortable it's something to know that
you could you you could if you wanted to
you know you never going to okay because
I was I was a singer I was you know I
was a single file save Andy for like a
while yeah and then I played Sona 5.
yeah and then I'm like no no no no no no
no
Choice every choice my choices have
consequence and you only have a certain
amount of time you can spend with people
okay this this requires multiple saves I
need to make sure I made the right
choice yeah yeah did I go back to any of
those savings absolutely not but
someone else on that day yeah I don't
know it's it's certainly with Persona 5
I actually use those multiple save files
because I actually wanted to like go
through all the routes and I was like
I'm not playing through the first 15
hours again just to get you know
you've completed it like three times I
have yes
but the first couple of times I was just
like no let's go back to the save file
and then I'm like that's not the same
I'll just start a new file